our latest winner
comes to you from the mid-atlantic and
the acc
and the quarterback it's our first
quarterback we've gone defensive lineman
offensive lineman defensive back
and now we've gone quarterback
not only because of what he did on the
field against clemson
but the fact that people who have played
for nc state beforehand have not been
able to do it with regularity against
clemson but also his story
the winner of the gorilla glue toughest
player on planet earth for this week is
devin leary
of nc state
32 of 44 238 yards four touchdowns no
picks
in nc state's win over clemson since
this
century was born in the year 2000
the only other nc state quarterbacks to
beat clemson are named mike lennon and
philip rivers who did it twice
and this is a comeback season for devin
leary
he broke his fibula last year
and missed the final seven games
and so
this performance earned him the davey
o'brien national quarterback of the week
award but we all know
that pales in comparison to being the
gorilla glue toughest player on planet
earth the nil deal of a thousand dollar
check
and all sorts of gorilla glue product
goes to
devin leary of nc state who joins us now
live on the rich island show how are you
devon
good how are you thank you so much for
the award it means a lot i appreciate
you saying that and it means a lot for
us to give it to you uh what were you
going through last year when you were
out for those seven weeks and what were
you thinking about in that pandemic
season devin yes sir it was it was tough
i'll admit um you know we got off to a
pretty good start early on um i think it
was about the fourth game of the season
against duke i went down with the injury
and
you know couldn't really feel my leg all
the way so
you know they kind of put the game in a
different perspective for me
it allowed new opportunities as far as
being able to study to defense more
being able to get into the film room
more and
i mean in long term it helped me out
tremendously
and what does it mean for you and your
program to beat clemson because your
as your college uh cohorts storm the
field after that w last saturday what
was that like devin yeah it was awesome
it was awesome i think it was huge not
only for our team but the entire
university itself um you know clemson
has done a great job over the past
couple years kind of being that standard
of the atc and being able to beat them
was huge for the entire university and i
was glad everyone was able to celebrate
the win
what was it like for you in the locker
room afterwards again on your surgical
surgically repaired leg that you were
able to come back and do something like
this
was that yeah it was it was such a
surreal feeling i mean you can't really
describe that that feeling of love that
you expressed with your brothers your
teammates i mean going through so much
being able to knock off a team like that
was huge for us and just the celebration
was incredible in there well you did
something i guess russell wilson
couldn't do right let's put it let's
just put a fine point on here devin
right yeah i guess so have you spoken to
anybody uh like like ross or or phillip
rivers or
or glennon or glennon as uh as john
gruden refers to him have you spoken any
of your
previous cohorts at the position
on that yeah so um actually this
offseason phillip rivers was able to
speak to us via zoom uh he spoke to the
entire team so that was really cool to
hear his message and then you know after
the game i got texts from both mike
glennon and ryan finley just
congratulating me telling me how happy
they were for me and it was a huge honor
that's so cool man what was philip
rivers message to you devin
what was his name it was really the
message to the entire team was just um
to compete in every all aspects of life
really
um being able to build that brotherhood
within your team but also being able to
hold people accountable is what
separates great teams from average teams
so just being able to hear that message
from him and just hear his passion and
his voice was very exciting that's
pretty cool
all right devon larry by the way mike
del tufo uh does devin leary sound like
a kid from new jersey to you or no
yeah of course no
devon where's that accent where what
exit are you from devon
i'm actually from sicklerville new
jersey um okay in south jersey about
15 20 minutes outside of philly i was
just going to say that you sort of have
like that philly accent in a way like i
heard that song so literally what exit
are you from garden state give it to me
uh i believe it's exit seven okay exit
seven and then and then what delaware
water gap on the turnpike exit one is
that where you're at or what
uh yeah i believe so okay more
importantly is it pork roll or taylor
ham
pork roll see south jersey
i have to go there with him
he's definitely south carolina you know
what it is now there it is now it's
gorilla glue yeah what are you gonna
glue together what do you need the glue
for devin come on let's get into it what
are you gluing together what's going on
i actually do have some things in my in
my apartment i need to fix up okay um
what do you got i got part of my sink is
actually chipped off a little bit i got
to fix that i can use the glue for that
for sure yeah we can't have that devon
you're the nc state wolf pack
quarterback we can have chips in your
ceramic we can't have that that's what
we got the gorilla group for damn
straight absolutely and congratulations
on the nil deal i know you're on cameo
is this
is this your first nil deal
yes sir yes sir uh besides cameo yes sir
this is the first one here we go let's
do it you sir again you earned it uh
obviously what we what you did clearly
against clemson is one thing but we just
love the the fact that you you were down
literally and out last year
and um and got your way back in and did
what you were able to do with you and
your teammates and you're a good team
guy there may be an eye in in devon but
you're a team guy and that's what we
love we love it
so connected thank you so much
congratulations and uh hey send us a
photograph of that sync once it's back
together okay would you do that
devon yeah i will you know obviously we
could say we'll keep in touch you know
throughout your football career but i
want to see the sink quite frankly okay
okay sounds good
you got it congratulations that's devin
lyric devin
yeah gorilla glue toughest player on
planet earth
for this week and the rich eisen show
this award is brought to you by gorilla
glue makers of high quality adhesives
and tapes much like the players this
award recognizes gorilla brings
toughness and strength to even the most
difficult household projects and repairs
like a chipped sink come on now can't
have that can't have that hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here